do internal parasites quickly become immune to iburemectin or fed bed? I'm going to take
you to iburemectin for quite a while, about three modes switch to paste, do not know the
study improvement or proxy. Well, the fed bed and iburemectin as far as parasite killers are
hold on with something. Oh yeah, also Megan said with the subscription thing here you have to factor
in shipping too so just remember that you know so wherever you are but we will typically
fill the order the day it comes in but if you set this up on a Friday afternoon you're not
it's not going to get filled till next Monday because our hours are we typically close at two to
30 out of Friday it's not going to get filled till next Monday and then it's going to take several
days to get there so you're going to have to do that you have to figure that out too best to play
in ahead of as much as possible. As far as internal parasites become immune to iburemectin and fed bed
I would say I don't think that that happens. I would caution you against thinking that all your
problems are from parasites so yes people can have parasites iburemectin and fed bed do kill
parasites but they kill specific parasites mainly parasites that are really intestinal some that
might be in the liver with liver flokes but they're not going to kill what a parasite might have done
to a person so let me give you an example it's very common with people with Lyme disease that
they may have been diagnosed with Lyme disease 10 years ago or let's say and they still have symptoms
that they're blaming it on the Lyme disease still. Well of course I got this all and I got ticked by
10 years ago I've never been the same sense okay so let's differentiate whether our symptoms are
from a current infection or from the effects of a past infection. It's really hard to get people
to understand this especially if they're in these Lyme groups on Facebook and all this stuff
everything is blamed on this disease just like you can blame everything on parasites or blame
everything on whatever okay we have to understand physiology 99% of the time your body will take care
of things your immune system will kill things especially if you ate it like in the case of a parasite
which is a multi-celled organism so it's a very it's much more difficult for your immune system to kill if
you take hypermectory and fed bed it's a parasite killing nutrition as things you can kill the parasite
but then why do I still have problems now X amount of months X amount of years later because a parasite
just like a bacteria like Borrelia burglarathy that causes Lyme disease could be long gone years and
years a decade ago it's dead it's not even in your body anymore but it did damage when
intracellular your immune system tried to kill it intracellular started to make antibodies against
different cell tissue lines and now you have cell tissue antibodies you guys if you're really
interested in stuff we've got to go on our autoimmune chronic disease in our immune module and start
watching some of those videos because that's how you're going to learn about this stuff you're not
going to fight it on Instagram and Facebook so you have to understand that most people that think
that they have parasites after they've done a ton of different parasite cleanses or think that
they have Lyme disease or think that they have this constant virus that they're trying to kill and
just can't kill Lyme disease I can't figure out why I can't try to kill Lyme disease I got this
flare again I'm not discalculating their symptoms I'm saying what are they really from we're not
from the living organisms still present they're from because the living organism was there in a specific
time in your life doesn't mean it's still there but it doesn't mean it didn't do damage so you could
have all sorts of things from it you could have microglill cryoid you could have autoimmune
formation meaning your body created immune antibodies against cell tissue and that's really
what your symptoms of your flares are from need to go under that course and learn that stuff
for you and your loved ones because that's a big reason why a person has chronic
comorbidities now when you're dealing with cancer you're made you're made focus on killing cancer
once you eat a state of remission now you're going to start focusing on what else could I do to deal with
these other symptoms I have in my body well you got to figure out what it is and what you need to
what they actually are so running some antibody tests can be beneficial but just because a person
has cancer doesn't mean they don't have comorbidities of autoimmune disease that's why I created that
whole course for you guys to learn that so go start taking it into that